we spoke just before the election and
you told me that you know you were
advising people to vote not for the
Conservatives but for maybe some of
those former conservatives who were
independents off the Liberal Democrats
they didn't listen to you why not well
you have to be modest about the role you
play in life they didn't listen because
they wanted to get out of the austerity
and they saw brexit as a route to do
that and I don't it's much more
complicated than that
so you know we've lost we have to face
up to that we're going to leave Europe
well with that admission and and to be
fair to you I mean it's it's good of you
to say that because a lot of people are
still saying well we're going to change
the fight we're going to keep that fight
going but you're saying are you that
actually it's time now to draw a line
well the reality is that Boris Johnson
has got a thumping parliamentary
majority and there's no way that they
will not get their legislation through
in very short order so we will leave the
European Union where then got a period
of uncertainty but frankly it's
pie-in-the-sky to start talking about
fighting on in the present circumstances
and I have no doubt told my fellow peers
in the House of Lords we'll take the
same view we are not there to defy the
will of the people and so what is your
feeling then what did you think when you
when that results started to come
through in that that very dramatic exit
poll of course I mean obviously a sense
of disappointment I guess that that the
what you were hoping for Europe wasn't
going to be wasn't going to be happening
but are you confident that a strong
Conservative government can bring
forward those one nation conservative
ideas which which you advocated during
your time in office well it's much
better than that isn't it because the
policies that I advocated were supported
first by Margaret Thatcher then John
Major and then David Cameron and what
were they they were
move heavy resources into the
restoration of formerly prosperous areas
that have seriously declined and the
next thing was to put someone in charge
either field Development Corporation's
but much more desirably through the
creation of local mares and we've now
got local mares in most of the big
conurbations and interestingly we have
mayors of conservative and labor policy
so there was a terrific opportunity for
the prime minister he won't win unless
he works with those mares but as he's a
former mayor himself and he's a very
practical politician he knows that
without me having to say it he's already
promised to raise the powers of the
mayors in the existing areas London
already his emeriti and the next
question is whether he's prepared to
frankly complete the reforms which have
been on the agenda for 60 years in order
to bring about unitary counties and to
give the proper leadership to those
counties because within them are quite a
lot of sort of towns and places that
have gone brexit so there's an urgency
and my own view is that Boris Johnson
knows that he's used language about that
and this is he has all the weapons which
have been used effectively but perhaps
not on a large enough scale by previous
Conservative government's so I mean what
would the fallout from that be the
result of that being you saying that
that would in in itself lead to greater
investment in deprived areas
particularly in the north and and almost
see you know in maybe in places like
Bligh Valley and other areas in
Northumberland and elsewhere see the
sort of regeneration which you created
in Canary Wharf well try Liverpool was a
better example you can every wolf was
within a stone's throw the City of
London it wasn't the biggest challenge
to try and spread that wealth changing
places like the humour station
Manchester and the banks of the Mersey
and many other similar places
Monte's site for example and the banks
of the Tyne and Newcastle the incredible
changes in manchester of Salford all of
these things followed the policies which
the Conservative government which I was
a member believed but there's one other
thing that I think the Prime Minister
should take seriously the divisions in
Whitehall the great Baron is of power
the specific functions of government
departments is an inhibitor to getting
coherent local policies working on the
ground and I think that it would be very
sensible for the Prime Minister in
looking at his cabinet to create a
minister to coordinate all those
essential features of Education
employment skills housing under one
cabinet committee in order to be able to
talk coherently to the mayors we've done
it locally they were now mayor's
responsible to all of these things but
when they look up to Whitehall they're
faced with a dozen different government
departments all with their own agenda
and with no effective coordinating
mechanism that would be an important
change to make as not just effective
management but as a signal that viruses
determined to see this thing through
which I personally believe he is because
he is a former mayor he knows the
advantages and he's always in my view
being a supporter of this agenda I mean
he's got a big incentive has me in terms
of of keeping on side those voters who
in his words lent him their vote in
traditional labour heartlands I mean he
really is going to happen I think you've
got to show them real differences I
think I think you put your nail on the
head absolutely that he there's no short
term solution to this issue you are
dealing with long terms issues of social
and structural decline so he has to get
on with it otherwise the election that
follows there will be retribution so
he's forced the bridgehead but he's now
got to hold the bridgehead
and if I give you another example of
knife
we've heard a huge amount about knife
crime and 20,000 extra police if you
look at the figures and you break them
down a year from now there won't be a
single extra policeman on the streets it
takes time to recruit and train and the
only way to deal with knife crime
seriously is to understand the social
conditions that have given rise to it
and the only way to do that is to earn
the trust of the communities from which
the perpetrators of knife crime come if
I may make a most obvious and rather
daunting thought the first person from
the public sector likely to spot the
potential knife crime addict is the
primary school teacher because these
things don't happen as a sort of rush of
blood it's age of 16 it's the dropouts
from school it's the broken families
it's the gang leaders all of that that
give to and create that culture which
leads to such devastating effect and if
I put advise boys
the first thing he should do would be to
call in the mayor's and say look you all
come from different parties now I want
each of you to come forward within six
months with a report about how we solve
this community tension which is creating
these conditions at the extreme and we
are out of time I'm sorry to say but I
do just want to actually one last point
you mean using your vast political
experience how does the Labour Party
reposition itself now well they should
get rid of Corbin full stop end of story
but can they move back to the center
ground is that a necessary move oh yeah
of course they can and they probably
will I mean they're huge numbers of
Labor Party supporters that I know
friends of mine who just believe the the
extraordinary deviation to no man's land
that the party took Michael has some
time it is always a pleasure to talk to
you sir thank you very much indeed
thank you thank you